hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the terms that you'll see lev
chesterf bringing up occasionally
throughout all things are possible is
groundlessness and this is going to
be an important way of characterizing
the
human condition running throughout his
entire
text and his larger work you could say
that
grappling with this is one of the
hallmarks of
chestoff's entire approach and he is an
existentialist
author drawing on other authors who
earlier
saw this problematic for example
nietzsche and dostoevsky who he talks
about quite a bit
in this work and it's going to be tied
together
with a treatment of what we can call
contingency now he doesn't use that term
all that often but it is a useful
philosophical term
for describing another
important aspect of our existence and
the reality that we encounter
namely that things could be other than
they they are
that it was not impossible
that they be different and therefore in
the future
we we don't actually circumscribe all
possibilities
even if we think that we do the
correlative of contingency would be
necessity when we say it's a sure
thing we're often engaging in a kind of
projection or wishful thinking because
as it turns out so many things that we
considered to be sure
things we find out aren't
and so the human condition the way that
chest off portrays it
is that we we live in a contingency that
we
discover progressively and we don't even
know
how contingent things are we might think
of contingency as being something
sort of like an on off switch something
like like a
continuum right some things are more
contingent other things are less
contingent some things are much more
dependent on variables
outside our control some things are less
so and when we're talking about
sort of ultimate realities or the
foundations of things
we we want to think that there's some
sort of necessity
that we can grasp but we don't actually
have enough tools we don't have enough
experience we don't have
enough of anything to really
justify that and yet continually we are
justifying a whole myriad of different
perspectives that we say we finally got
it and it's very interesting if you
if you think about when he's writing
this in the early
1900s right the things that he's saying
today
we have people in our new millennium
saying exactly the same things just a
slightly different content we finally
figured it all out
i actually had a person comment on
another
chest of discussion saying oh we're you
know modern science is almost
at the end of figuring out exactly how
the universe works
and you know what the fundamental bases
are you know
we've heard that tune before and people
have been saying that
for a number of years and we might
actually be better off being like the
epicureans who are going to talk about
in just a moment and saying
here's the best we've got and you know
natural science is is interesting and it
can be a great distraction it can help
us
free ourselves from some prejudices
which would otherwise be bothering us
but does it reveal to us the actual
state of the universe no
and even if it did would that tell us
what we need to know about
the fundamental problems of human
existence probably not
so we're always projecting beyond our
experience
and chest off is somebody who is writing
in a you know conscient time also a post
schopenhauer nietzsche time
and he's going back in some respects to
david hume
you know saying well you know this
old-fashioned skepticism
by chef's time that hume was evincing
might actually be kind of helpful for us
the realization that from the basis of
our
limited experience we really can't
conclude with
absolute certainty or necessity all that
much and yet people are doing this all
the time
now there's there's really two things
that are going
on in modernity that make for
you might say a somewhat newer condition
something that nietzsche
and dostoevsky each of them and their
turn were
totally attuned to right and that is
that the development
of let's call it not just the sciences
but the disciplines
help to reveal to us just how contingent
things really are and
how often we've been off base and how
the sciences themselves
often lack a grounding that they
operate as if they had at one point
in the work shasta says sciences really
have nothing to do with truth they have
you know to do with results being able
to put things into
a certain classificatory scheme and so
through the development this is
something that nietzsche says in the
genealogy of morals and also in
the birth of tragedy we become aware
of the radical contingency the
groundlessness
of all sorts of things and we also
could just be operating in you know our
own ordinary
world of you might say common sense and
also come to realize that the things
that we depend on
don't really have foundations the way we
think they do they are contingent what
foundations they have is largely
on the basis that we desire them to to
be so or
they work well for society seemingly and
everybody talks about them that way but
when you really poke and prod
you find that there's nothing supporting
them and there's all sorts of attempts
that are made to either dispel
or ignore or remedy this condition
this has been going on for for quite
some time as a matter of fact you can
look back into antiquity and see
similar responses but it's intensified
in our modern condition so
we have a few mentions that we should
take a look at that flesh this
this notion out the first one
is in chapter 17 of
the here we go of part one
he's talking about russian literature
and then he talks about
uh trajania and this long article called
tropman's execution
and he says the description produces a
soul-shaking effect on the reader
i think i shall not exaggerate if i say
this is one of the best at least one of
the most vigorous of
turgenia's writings um you know tolstoy
also describes similar things
and then he brings up one one sort of
example from this
the executioners like spiders on a fly
threw themselves on tropman and bore him
to the ground and then
turgenia says the earth quietly swam
away from under my feet
so we're forced to believe him this is
an experience that we can actually have
it's
it's a experience of what he calls the
horrors of existence
he says men respond only faintly to the
horrors that take place around them
except at moments
when the savage crying incongruity and
ghastliness of our condition
suddenly reveals itself vivid before our
eyes and we are
forced to know what we are then the
ground
slides away from under our feet
and you know does this mean that like
the earth actually moves away from under
us
no of course not but there's a feeling
a sensation a affect of
things slipping away this is something
that's a really
you know major existentialist theme we
see this being discussed by
writers as varied as you know as i
mentioned
dostoevsky and nietzsche kierkegaard
also talks about this sort of thing
heidegger will talk about it in terms of
the nothing
and sartre will talk about it as well in
terms of nausea term by the way that
nietzsche also
uses to describe this this realization
of incongruities and horror and a lack
of grounding a lack of ultimate
explanation a lack of
meaningfulness this is something that's
being experienced
through watching the execution of
another person but it could happen in so
many
other ways and so he goes on and he says
this doesn't happen for long the horror
of the sensation of groundlessness
quickly brings man to himself he must
forget everything
he must only get his feet on the earth
again
and you know this is this is quite
interesting
what we have is a sort of a natural
tendency to want to say no no no
everything is okay i'm just going to
find some
explanation for this or you know have a
faith that an explanation will be
eventually provided and he says that
um tregeniev in his diary of a
superfluous man
um you know was was proving himself in
his riskiest state
as when as a young man he wrote this
this diary
and he says the description of tropman's
execution ends with these words
who can fail to feel that the question
of capital punishment is one of the most
urgent immediate problems
which humanity must settle
and why why does it have to be settled
because it is confronting people with
things
with with horrors with you know
injustices
with something that says this does not
make sense this is absurd
and there's no easy explanation for it
so
you know that that's kind of a good way
to
to understand how this can appear to us
he also talks about groundless
assumptions
in a chapter that has that very title
this is quite interesting he says
groundless assumptions based on nothing
because they seem to derive from
a common assumption of the
reasonableness of human existence
this is something that again we're
projecting our desires onto
existence an assumption which surely is
the child of our desires
and probably a bastard at that isn't
that an interesting way to frame it
right he's
very good with turns and phrases like
that so it's a child of our desires it's
a product of our desires
and an illegitimate one at that
so he talks about all sorts of you know
examples of this
in here and you know
how can we avoid making groundless
assumptions
it's very difficult for us it's very
difficult not to buy into something
even if we reject what society is
providing us with
we have an entire batch of things within
ourselves he's got you know great
example here
of the miser uh in in one of gogol's
stories right he says that gogol with
his
polishkin creates a repulsive figure of
a miser he was nearer to reality a miser
is ugly whatever view you take of him
inward
and outward he's possessed by one desire
to everything else to all happenings
he's indifferent
it's the same to him whether he's hungry
or full warm or cold clean or dirty
he's disinterestedly mean we may say so
and the assumptions that the miser is
making are just as groundless
as the you know we might say fabric of
nonsense
that everybody else is pursuing saying
it's important to have a nice
tie it's important to have a good name
it's important to do this to do that
and here's how you do it everybody's
sort of
making it up as they go along without
realizing it and very often
in a crowd of people who are doing that
now if you if you start to realize that
you could thematize this
into something philosophical or
cultural and one of the great dangers of
an awareness of groundlessness
is what uh now uh chef doesn't use the
term
nihilism but it's something that
certainly is in the air
and you know could well describe what
he's talking about
as the cult of groundlessness so there's
a very interesting
discussion a little bit later in the
book in a long
chapter number 14 and we're going to
look at part of this and then go
backwards into it
so he tells us that
in the the cultural situation that we've
reached we have uh come to a to a point
where now
at least for certain avant-garde elites
who are you know sort of prefiguring
where the rest of mankind is going
we are moving into seemingly a new era
he says
for thousands of years man has sought to
solve the great mystery of life
through a god conception with theodicy
and metaphysical theories as a result
both of which deny the possibility of a
mystery theodicy has long ago
wearied us theodicy is you know some
sort of explanation on the basis of the
nature of god or how god interacts with
the
universe
and and you can do this in other ways
you don't necessarily have to have god
you can do it in terms of history
or the party or you know american
freedom or whatever you like
it all winds up being the same basic bs
explanation and people don't really buy
it
why not because they've got good reasons
not to buy it you know the logic doesn't
actually hold up
he says that the mechanistic theories
which contend there's nothing special in
life
these look more plausible at first sight
but people don't take to them
and no theory can survive men's
reluctance to believe in it
you know people come up with all sorts
of you know scientific
logical theories you know they're as
contingent and groundless as anything
else and
you know the real test for that is
people after their initial enthusiasm
for
in our time for example neuro everything
you know they're like
this doesn't really do what i wanted it
to do it doesn't provide a real
explanation and he says so over wrought
mankind is turned from its old idols and
here's where the
crucial turn goes and enthroned madness
and evil right uh
he goes on and he says this is solipsism
and the cult of
groundlessness and you know if you if
you look
back at the stuff that he's talking
about like for example the decadence
of the late 1800s and early 1900s
some of the stuff that they say is kind
of quaint but i mean if you spend a lot
of time on the internet
and look at the nihilism involved in
certain movements that are going on
nihilism that's at the basis
of their their theories if we want to
call them that
where there's really a kind of
groundlessness that people are terrified
of
and then they're justifying all sorts of
you know crazy stuff based on like
evolutionary psychology which is
as shaky as science as you could
possibly find in the in the present
right so many assumptions being made
involved in that
um well some people embrace it and
they're like
i'm gonna take the black pill i'm you
know i'm gonna be
nihilistic so in his time he calls this
the cult of groundlessness
and he says now here's where it's
interesting
the cult of groundlessness and solipsism
are not lasting and most of all they're
not to be
handed down they're not sustainable as
we would say
right and so they're sort of like a
halfway house somebody goes into them
and then they come right back out a
little bit later
into something else they become just a
straight out hedonist right
or they just become an abusive person
working out their own traumas and cycles
based on once again
some good mixture of groundless
assumptions and mischaracterizations of
things
or they find some crusade to go on
whether it be on the left or the right
or you know they find a new religion or
whatever it's going to be
right and he goes on and he says the
final triumph
rests with goodness and common sense
history has known many epochs like ours
and gone through with them
degeneration follows on the heels of a
moderate curiosity
and sweeps away all refined and
exaggerated well-informed individuals
right so sooner or later you
wind up leaving this sort of thing and
even a culture
can't sustain that for good all the
things that people have is these great
boogie men you know about you know our
current situation
and how it's against this and against
that you know in the criticizing
post-modernism
or you know saying the enlightenment was
totally bad or any of these sorts of
things
these really are not sustainable ideas
over time what makes them sustainable is
people believe your bs
and encourage you and coddle you and
give you money
and then you can go on with that but
it's all groundless at the bottom
right even the the sort of cult of
groundlessness
is groundless and certain human dynamics
will reassert themselves
not that we can actually trust those 100
percent and see in those
a kind of necessity this is not a you
know eternal recurrence conservativism
on the part of shasta if he thinks
that's just as much groundless
you know silliness as anything else
but um it is kind of good news
right so the last thing that he says
is very early in the work and i think
this
gives us a clue about what he thinks
we ought to be doing he says that um
in spite of epicurus and his
exasperation we're forced to admit
anything whatsoever may result from
anything
whatsoever but that doesn't mean that a
stone ever turned into bread
or that our visible universe was ever
naturally formed from nebulous puffs
from our own minds and our own
experience we can deduce nothing that
would serve as a ground
for setting even the smallest limit to
nature's own arbitrary
behavior so there is a kind of
groundlessness to nature there is a
groundlessness within human nature
and society anything can result from
anything it doesn't always work that way
obviously but we can't set some absolute
limits he says if whatever happens now a
chance to happen differently it would
not therefore have seemed any the less
natural
to us so although there may be an
element of inevitability in our human
judgments concerning natural phenomena
we have never been able and probably
never shall be able to separate the
grain
of inevitable from the chaff of
accidental and
casual truth and we don't even know
which is the most
essential and important the inevitable
or the
casual we're and we're probably never
going to know this sort of thing even if
we do make progress
in the sciences as he points out later
on in a discussion of science he says
you know the sciences they make advances
they do so
precisely by ignoring the vast majority
of people's experiences right they
zero in on the ones that can be
reproduced and explained
and they ignore everything else
so what should we do he says we're
forced to the conclusion that philosophy
must give up her attempt at finding the
very tatus iternae
the eternal truths the providing some
sort of ground
we should recognize groundlessness and
contingency
and then what should we do after that
here's where he tells us that the
business of philosophy
is to teach man to live in uncertainty
man who is supremely afraid of
uncertainty and who is forever
hiding himself behind this or the the
other dogma
the business of philosophy is not to
reassure people
but to upset them and so
the philosopher has according to this a
task of
living a life that can actually
address the contingency of our existence
and everything that we experience
and the groundlessness of
that whole existence and all the
explanations that we
try to provide to make sense of it to
figure out how to act within it
doesn't mean that we can't have theories
doesn't mean that we can't have
even world philosophies belt on
xiaohangen
right a word that he uses to describe
philosophies as sort of like an
overarching conception of the world
we can have a philosophy as a way of
life but we have to realize that we're
doing so
without any ultimate grounding and so
this is definitely sort of
an existentialist moment in his works
you